I know that you don't like to talk about your life
but a guy with a freaking machete foreign
arm just chopped our butts in half
who are you on september 3rd my father trained
me to be an assassin that's not who i am
you're such a badass thank you hello
everyone we're from the cast of marvel
studios shang chi and the legend of the
10 rings and today we're going to play
a game that'll hopefully let you know
a little bit more about our characters
you got this don't be nervous thank you who is
most likely to get into a fight me that sounds
fast yes right yes like your character or you
i just want to make sure that you know also you
you're like such a badass everything that
you do is like so cool who is most likely to
joke their way out of a confrontation you you
think it's me sean would would make a snarky
like uh well let's go big boy shang
is known to say that i'm ready to
rumble that's right i don't know what one
but what men say why is so big big boy
who's most likely to survive a
zombie apocalypse both of you guys
you have superhero genetics are you kidding
me but here's the thing how many times can
you punch a zombie without like without
getting bit oh right who's most likely to
fall for a phone scammer definitely me and
that was one time and it was just my social
no really a couple times who's most likely
to order a coffee drink with more than
five words i don't know i've never done that
character work before i gotta really reach down
and go like what does my character want for
coffee who is most likely to save the world
trick question all of us it's all of us we save
the world together because we're a super team
Welcome back this is my new marvel shang chi
trailer video marvel dropped a bunch of new
footage there's a bunch of easter eggs we'll
break it all down i know a lot of you are also
asking how does this tie in with the history of
the mcu why is the mandarin waiting till present
day to do everything that he's doing right now
i have a theory about that and it has something
to do with the plot of guardians of the galaxy 2
some similarities in what's going on between the
plot of that movie and this movie and also some
of the connections to the iron man movies and the
backstory that we got about the real mandarin
during that one shot all hail the king so if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos i will be doing full episode
videos for marvel's what if series that starts
next week too so it's a really good time to be
a marvel fan this summer the zombies name drop is
also very timely because we're going to be seeing
a whole bunch of that marvel zombies story line
during the what if episodes you have to imagine
what a live-action version of that might look like
but just starting with the brand new scenes the
brand new footage they start with his friend katie
played by awkwafina freaking out asking him about
who he really is after their big san francisco bus
fight scene where razer fist and mandarin's men
come to abduct him and force him to come back to
their father's fortress based on this now it seems
like that's happening at the very beginning of the
movie because he seems like he's been friends with
katie for a long time well he's been on his crazy
version of rum springer for the last 10 years
trying to avoid his father as much as possible
what marvel has done is just combine the fu manchu
character with the iron man villain the mandarin
in the comics fu manchu was training his son
shang chi to take his place take over his
criminal empire and in the iron man comics
when you're getting the history of the mandarin
character he doesn't really have a giant family or
anything like that the ten rings of power give him
near immortality he just keeps leaving on and on
and on because of his precious make all the lord
of the rings rings of power jokes that you want
i have not seen marvel reveal what his fake
name is that he's using during this 10-year
period because it sounds like he's telling katie
his name is shang chi for the first time like
it's the first time he's said that name in a long
period there's a lot more footage of kd and his
sister in here too and i believe the idea with the
katy character is that she's just like a normal
american girl that he meets makes friends with and
they're just having fun living their lives when
his father comes back to take him home even though
later in the trailer in what seems like the big
final battle that they're having in that ancient
village you see katie dressed like the monks in
those red robes wielding one of their special bows
and arrows laced with that red and orange energy
i will explain what i think is going on with
that in a second but i still think despite the
fact she gets a big hawkeye upgrade later in
the movie she's still supposed to be a pretty
normal character i'm sure clint would be proud
if elaine and bolova weren't so busy trying to
kill him cannot wait to see that play out
during the hawkeye episodes later this year
but then when each of the actors are talking
about their characters getting into fights
saving the world you see all the new footage of
his sister and the way they're explaining her as
far as we've seen is that she's just his younger
sister who stayed behind when he left 10 years ago
and they haven't seen each other in that 10-year
period so when they're fighting each other in
the ring during the tournament after the big
abomination versus wong fight after abomination
just hands wong his ass he's super surprised to
see her and just caught off guard because the last
time he would have seen her she would have been
this tiny little girl but in the last 10 years
she was being trained as an assassin just like
he was in all these flashbacks but the way the
dynamic seems like it plays out between the
three of them the mandarin and his two children
is that he really wants shang chi to come back and
take his place or he needs shang chi to come back
and i'll explain why in a second it just seems
like the mandarin doesn't really care about what's
going on with his daughter like okay i appreciate
that you're working so hard to be just as badass
of an assassin as your brother but my empire all
this power is going to be going to your brother
he's the important one but it seems like once they
fight it out in the ring they reconnect over their
mutual dislike of their father like after the
tournament it seems like everything chills out
here where katie starts fawning over her like
oh my god you're so badass i can't believe you
fight so well and then it seems like just based on
the way this footage plays out that's when death
dealer and the rest of his father's army swoop in
and raid the tournament here like everything goes
crazy and everyone starts running out of the ring
then they have the big fight in the high-rise and
then they return to his father the mandarin's
fortress you also notice too both he and his
sister are wearing the green jewels around their
neck like he's wearing the green jewel even in
the flashbacks when he's with his mother here you
see him wearing it at present day but his sister
is also wearing it so that sounds like it has
something to do with their family's history his
mother and this secret ancient village with these
monks the whole thing with death dealer we haven't
seen a whole lot from them in the trailer so i'm
guessing that they're just sort of like a sub boss
mid villain and not a really huge character in
the movie in the comics that character was a
secret double agent working inside mi6 for shang
chi's father who at that time in the comics was fu
manchu leading a criminal empire so death dealer
was working for fu manchu but because they've
combined that character with the mandarin in the
movie i think they're just changing death dealer's
origin story and saying that he just been one of
his father's chief lieutenants this whole time
it's just that anytime you see a character
who's wearing a mask at all times in a trailer
you wonder if they're hiding a secret under
there what i think is going on with all their
special weapons here in the ancient village and
all this new footage is because the energy that
they give off seems very similar to the energy
being given off by the mandarin's bluish energy
of the ten rings i think it's related to whatever
marvel is doing with the mcluhans inside the mcu
however they're going to explain the origin of the
great protector dragon the origin of the ten rings
of power like all these weapons that they're
wielding here seems like they're either dragon
scales or dragon hide that they've just fashioned
into weapons in the red orange energy that they
give off is just tied to the dragon's power like
this red door that you see behind them here when
shang chi is fighting his father whatever it
is the mandarin is trying to get that's behind
this seal whatever he's trying to open up here is
the exact same energy signature as these weapons
now in the comics the door would have just hidden
the dragon's spaceship the mcluhan spaceship that
had crashed on earth but i'm assuming because
they've already changed so much about what's
going on with these dragons in the mcu whatever
this seal is protecting whatever it's hiding is
going to be different as well and when i said i
think they're going for similar guardians of the
galaxy 2 type of twist here so during guardians 2
the whole reason why ego the living planet needed
peter quill his son was because he needed his
celestial dna to complete his mission of taking
over the universe so when all the actors during
this trailer say that they all get to save the
world the idea is what is the mandarin doing that
threatens the entire planet probably has something
to do behind this door i think the difference
in the mandarin is that he does genuinely care
about his children whereas ego the living planet
didn't really care about peter quill at all but
the mandarin is a marvel villain at the end of the
day and shangxi's mother may have belonged to this
group of monks she may have some sort of genetic
tie to this group of people and they might somehow
be related to the dragons here like the great
protector dragon so early theory shang chi might
be half dragon the way that peter quill was half
celestial and maybe the idea is that only the
dragons like the great protector dragon could
open up this giant seal this giant door and get
whatever's behind it and maybe the only way the
mandarin can get whatever is in here is with shang
chi's help and that's why he's so important to him
during the movie otherwise why would the mandarin
be waiting so long to try and go after this if
he wasn't waiting for shang chi to grow up mature
come into his own power so this whole time in the
mcu the mandarin has kind of been trying to win
shang chi over trying to train him to fight these
monks to get whatever's behind this seal like a
very long-played darth vader luke skywalker come
to the dark side kind of thing imagine darth vader
had found luke skywalker when luke was a young
child and tried to spend his entire upbringing
winning him over to the dark side also tying this
back to the plot of the iron man movies because
mandarin is a big iron man villain it sounds
like one of the reasons why the mandarin
wanted stark tech weapons so bad in why he was
using the ten rings organization through this
group of people to take the stark tech weapons
was all in service of his ultimate plan of taking
this ancient village defeating these monks
so they could get whatever's behind the seal
the cool thing about the last big trailer
they just released too is that kevin feige
was basically saying that it was the real mandarin
the whole time when woo this character tony lung's
character who was behind the hit on iron man
to try and take his weapons so even though it
wasn't his intention he inadvertently became the
reason why tony stark became iron man in the mcu
i'm expecting a lot of easter eggs from the iron
man movies in general so we'll see if they include
any easter eggs for trevor just that hanging plot
thread with him being taken at the end of that one
shot all hail the king all we need is like one
shot of a dungeon inside the mandarin's fortress
with trevor just complaining for like two seconds
maybe in like a funny post-credits scene but if
you spotted any brand new easter eggs in this
trailer footage that i didn't talk about during
the video just write it below in the comments and
big reminder my marvel what if episode 1 video
will post next wednesday it is going to be crazy
and i'm also working on a full suicide squad movie
breakdown and easter eggs for the entire movie
that should post tomorrow while you wait for
everything click here for my video on the suicide
squad movie post credit scenes and ending scenes
and click here for that brand new marvel what
if episode 1 trailer and even more easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!